hey sona hi conan how are you yeah i'm
okay
yeah you feeling all right no i'm not
i'm
very pregnant but i'm okay you were
incredibly pregnant
i found out today i have two babies that
are both weighing
over six pounds wow i'm carrying 12
pounds of just human that sounds like
they're fully clothed in utero
they're wearing heavy corduroy jackets
and they've got
work boots on that's 48 mcdonald's
quarter pounders
good god now i want mcdonald's
[Laughter]
but um that's that's a lot of baby yeah
i will compliment you
and matt you will back me up on this you
have visited the show a couple of times
recently
yeah you're not allowed to drive uh but
your
very nice cool husband tac drives you
and you'll visit us
on the set and everyone says the same
thing you have
two babies and they're all concentrated
in this one area
of your body and the rest of you just
looks
amazing you're just like not that i mean
that's true and
all the women are freaked out they're
like oh my god if you just
you know didn't know yeah if you didn't
look at that one part of your body where
it looks like someone is trying to hide
um i'll just say it uh one of those mini
fridges
under your under your dress oh you
really romanticize
pregnancy yeah yeah well instead of you
know some coors light you've got
two 26 pound babies in you um
but no but you're you really look
amazing that's what i'm saying it took
me a long time to get there but everyone
says it you look very beautiful that's
very nice i feel like i kind of actually
maybe lost weight but
uh yeah which is weird but i'm cool i
feel like i'm crushing it
and uh yeah i'm just ready you're ready
this is the stage i remember my wife
both times being very ready towards the
end like
i think she said get this monster out of
me yeah that's what she said
i'm ready yeah sleeping moving
doing anything i'm ready right and what
about you
uh matt i'm good i'm hanging in there i
mean
i'm no champ like sona you're an
inspiration sona you look amazing
and it's incredible all you do during
all of this thanks man
i think welcome science is gonna make
make it possible
for a man to carry a child i would love
to i would love to
would you yes i would i'm kind of
jealous i'm gonna be very honest i'm not
jealous at all
i think you're insane really the miracle
of childbirth
yeah but i just i i'm freaking me out
right now
just thinking about it girly think about
you carrying a child
um yeah think about it yeah waddle in
i sit down and i go ah
hi guys well that's not that different
from what you do now i know
you don't really waddle but you're not
this transformation that you just went
into is the first man to give birth
nothing no let's see yeah ah
hi guys no i um it is of course the
miracle
it is twins and you're going to
instantly
have these two humans yeah yeah i am
um any thoughts about uh
what they might look like do you ever
try and picture them i think they're
gonna be
two little hairy armenian babies
i don't know how to they're gonna be you
know like
olive skinned they're gonna have a lot
of hair
you make it something they're gonna be
born fully bearded
are they gonna have thick beards eight
pounds of that twelve is just hair
yeah heavy they can have beards by the
time they're like two
i think i don't know wow yeah i don't
know they'll be born and then like
literally three hours later they'll have
to shave
the nurse is here no i'm fine i can
breastfeed no no she's here to shave
them
she's just wearing a barber's small
she's yeah she's like i'll take care of
that
the baby's like what are you reading the
papers
um you're gonna want to eat hummus
instead of
breast milk i was when i was born my mom
said
that i was a fat little buddha a little
fat baby
oh wow and she said that i had uh bright
orange
wispy orangutan hair that was like
sticking straight up adorable
yeah she said in a loving way or was she
like i was horrified
no she was not horrified but i was the
only one there
i'm you know six siblings in my family
and i was the only one with that kind of
orange copper hair and so it was you
know
even when i showed up you know people
were like what's this all about
you know there's a buzz that went
through the hallway oh come on and
people were like
this kid's gonna do things someday
someday
he's gonna have a podcast i was a a
really ugly baby and my mom cried
when she's what really yeah and she
loves telling me this
story which is i don't know why but
she's she cried because she thought i
was ugly and then the nurse was like
she's not always gonna look like that
i'm preparing you things can get mushed
around a little bit um
my daughter when she was born was
absolutely beautiful just stunningly
beautiful and
my son is a very handsome young man very
good-looking
guy yes he is and um but when he was
born
you know it's it's quite a traumatic
process and the face is very
malleable when the child is born so
um uh i gotta look at the baby
and so did liza and uh we were
we were uh concerned because he
looked like ed asner after a bar fight
he really did god looked like he had
gone like he had fought off like six
people
he looked like an angry old sports
writer uh who had tried his hand at
boxing
and it hadn't gone well that's what he
looked like and we were just like oh
well i'm sure he'll be a kind person
oh my god and then um literally within
like three days he started to look
completely different
and i i was like oh right you know the
trauma of childbirth that's gonna say
thank god he has no memory of that but
you've recorded it here for all time oh
no
every day i tell him man you for i mean
every day at breakfast he'll show he'll
he'll arrive and i'll say man when you
showed up
you were just a hot [ __ ] mess
and then i'm like waffles